et l'on montre son ange qui l'a fabriqué
tout seul sous le regard de son frère et
de sa maman
cette famille a participé à l'atelier
drôle d'ange à la maison de
l'environnement à magny les hameaux des
réalisations de décorations de noël en
matières recyclées et les enfants n'ont
pas manqué d'imagination et déjà fait un
nom jeu comme les autres sauf que j'ai
rajouté des pieds et des boutons le
corps j'ai fait un carton au lieu des 0
par tour et les sièges des plastiques
mais là encore le plastique bon à les
accrocher
et puis on va mettre de la laine je
pense qu'on va continuer à la maison on
va rajouter des choses des couleurs
peut-être un bon voilà comme ils veulent
et de ce côté là maintenant passer mais
il y en a deux côtés mais il doit
transformer la matière première en fait
en la découpant on n'utilise que du les
ciseaux et des liens pour fixer on n'a
pas de colle et ça donc voila c'était un
peu le but aussi se débrouiller sans
colle son scotch à leur disposition des
bouchons en plastique des assiettes en
carton du fil de fer et du sac plastique
l'objet premier d'une façon écologique
de concevoir ses décorations de fêtes